mine it's actually not my job to answer
your questions I've asked you two
questions should a mass stay in power
and are they a terror group you're
refusing to answer either of them that
is very telling talk TV is the only
place where you get the truth you've
done a book on poetry poetry and music
for the many I love poetry we can agree
on
that on TV on Radio and on your
smartphone Mr rishy sunak who had just
given the country his five big pledges
for how he wanted to improve Britain's
fortunes and in that interview he said
come back in a year's time and tell me
how you think I've done by the end of
the year when hopefully we can come back
and do this again and you can give me my
report card so I took him up on his word
and I'm back here at number 10 and I'm
about to go inside and tell the Prime
Minister exactly how I think he's done
can you you say you have grown the
economy NHS waiting list you failed on
that PL can I tell you a personal story
yeah that is a shocking story I've never
understood this Rwanda thing it seems to
me a completely cack-handed policy why
is this the hill you want to die on but
you don't have an alternative way to
solve that problem I'm not prime
minister when are you going to call the
[Music]
election prime minister how are how are
you I'm good thanks how are you well it
was a year ago we sat In This Very Room
in these very chairs you just had them
all done up actually it's very nice um
and you said to me then right I've just
done these five main pledges come back
in a year and judge me on how I've done
I did and I'm going to do that uh but
before we get to the the five pledges
and thank you for keeping the sixth
pledge which I appreciate um how are you
finding it being prime minister you just
become Prime Minister last time and it
was once described to me by someone who'
been prime minister that it's when you
first get the job it's like being in a
choppy ocean and you're getting hit by
wave after wave after wave and you think
my God I'm I'm drowning and then you
start to realize it always like that and
you start to ride the waves and enjoy it
more are you finding that well I think
when we were here a year ago you
described it as the worst Hospital pass
for any incoming prime minister ever and
I knew it wasn't going to be easy and
look candidly country's been through a
lot in the last couple of years we had
covid and all the impact that had Legacy
of backlogs and public services then we
had a war in Ukraine with all the impact
that had on energy bills so there's a
lot that happened the last time I saw
you was a a hilarious by chance moment
uh midair on a plane flying to Los
Angeles for what was your only family
holiday I believe in the last four and a
half years yeah I mean how how bad a
moment was that when you dusted yourself
down
laid back looked to your right and saw
me sitting there it was
fine it was fine I think we had a good
chat about Cricket I think I'll through
the fight no it's fine no actually I was
excited to be to actually because you
say family is important to me I don't
spend enough time with my kids as a
result of the job is it cool to have you
as a dad at school or is it not very
cool I think probably not very
cool I did a brief focus group this
morning as I was on my way here um and
in fact when I got here I asked my build
Terry I'm interviewing the Prime
Minister what do you want he said cut my
bleep
taxes uh I asked one of my best village
mates he said tell him to get a
grip and then I asked your policeman on
the way in he said do something about
police
wages so there you are there's a St po
there's a which didn't surprise me
because uh everybody if you ask them
right what do you want from the Prime
Minister they'll all have a bit of
self-interest about it and we're living
in a time when it's difficult right it's
not easy street out there for almost
anybody yeah I I think I think most
fair-minded people recognize that it is
difficult it was difficult when I got
the job but I also think that we're
making progress well you know we are now
starting to be able to cut people's
taxes everyone in their pay sliping the
last week in January has got the start
of a tax cut that's worth 450 quids is
it fair to say that right now you will
not be able to in the in the short term
the next budget cut the taxes as much as
you would have liked to now I never get
into this budget speculation but the
direction of travel is clear but we've
always said we have to do that
responsibly right and it has to be part
of a plan and we've started that so the
first tax cuts come in it's meaningful
but if we stick to the plan then yes
we'd like to cut more taxes are you
mindful constantly that your predecessor
lasted less than 50 days in fact in the
end couldn't out survive a lece because
she decided to just dramatically cut
taxes and tank the economy in the pound
are you constantly reminding yourself
youve Got To Tread carefully here yeah I
mean that's we had a debate over it that
that summer about our approaches and I
can't change the past but that's really
actually you talk about that moment
that's why I did this job because it was
that moment in time country was in a
tough spot and I felt that I could make
a difference I've got an economic
background I think people trust that I
know what I'm doing when it comes to the
economy and at that moment I thought
country's I said in a difficult spot and
I love this country more than anything
it's done an enormous amount for my
family and I can make a difference I've
interviewed a lot of prime ministers and
I don't for a moment think that you
don't have a very difficult job it's
just whether you can persuade people
this year as the clock ticks down to
whenever you call that election whether
you can persuade people in that time
that you're the guy to lead us out of
this or not when we get to that election
ultimately it's a choice it's not just
about me and what I'm doing it's about
me or k armor in the labor party and I'd
say there look the guy's been leader of
the opposition for four years he can't
tell you what he do differently cuz he
doesn't have a plan and you don't bring
about any positive change in our country
Charisma battle between you two look I'm
not interested in that what I'm
interested in is who can bring about you
think you're you think you're more
charismatic other people would judge but
what I does it matter to be the battle
that I want to win is this right the
battle I want to win is that people can
see that actually who's more likely to
bring about that positive change that I
want to see and I want them to realize
that actually it's me with a plan that
is working and they can see that in
spite of how difficult things have been
the fact that the plan we put in place
is starting to show progress will give
them the confidence that I can deliver
the change they want that's the battle
that I want to
win we're here thanks for joining us
you're with talk TV on TV on radio
online and we're on your smart
speaking criminals to using XL Bully
dogs as weapons to threaten others no
matter how well trained most dog owners
will tell you a dog can turn you know
what I love about talk today we do it
all sunak sella
scon woman can become a man and a man
can become a woman and if you think that
you're certifiably
insane slick Wishy seemed intelligent
forensic even a bit of a Statesman the
type of man you trust to look after your
house while you went on
holiday this concept that actually kids
wouldn't carry knives if they could go
and play Tiddly Winks that the you know
the corner over Street or whatever I
think it's a
nonsense happy THS night we slick it Kur
and timorous beasty open up panics in
nist K stas accused the government of
failing a generation after record number
of young people were killed last year
using a knife or sharp object we need to
make sure that when we say we're going
to ban them we actually do ban them
there are so many politicians now who
just said my dad was a
BOS you're David camera no he
wasn't was like brought to you by St KH
the mayor of London very rarely meet
anybody that says you know the thing
about London it's got a great mayor it's
a deep C brilliant
guy in the cities there are areas where
there are no vegetables it's
particularly difficult for those people
to do what Mark is saying if he comes up
with this argument again I'll sit on
him stop creating all of these funny
little factions with their funny little
names the new conservatives the ERG the
common sense research group the red wool
red trouser popcorn I mean popcorn what
what is that if you're talking about
multiculturalism it's workingclass white
boys who get put in the Army the poorest
people in society are the ones who are
going to be put on the front line
something is going horribly wrong we can
do a lot better Donald Trump didn't just
win he obliterated this is a guy facing
nearly a 100 criminal charges and yet
all that's done is actually Mak him more
popular Trump is canny enough to know
that all publicity is good publicity I
don't want a president who's been
impeached if he's able to bamboozle you
or that's the way it comes but did my 6
months I came back nobody would touch me
I put my head down I persisted I carry
down when I say I am God I'm not joking
did you feel Elvis was controlling I've
been answering your question you answer
mine it's actually not my job to answer
your questions I've asked you two
questions should a mass stay in power
and are they a terror group you're
refusing to answer either of them that
is very telling talk TV is the only
place where you get the truth you've
done a book on poetry poetry and music
for the many I love poetry we can agree
on
[Music]
that we've had two British politicians
murdered in in the last eight years or
so and we've just had your Justice
Minister mik FR saying he's going to
quit Parliament at the next election
after a series of death threats from
islamist extremists and an Arsen attack
on his constituency office and he said
that he escaped being killed by David
amus his Killer by the skin of his teeth
because he happened to not be in his
constituency when that killer was
looking at his office but you have
obviously I presume a lot of threats but
you have a lot of security that deals
with it that goes with the job as it
does in many of the offices of state but
the average MP doesn't have that and it
just struck me is it not time and is it
in your gift to do this to actually give
every single member of parliament on
both s all parties a a bodyguard a
security guard I think the public would
support that I don't want to see more
elected officials
murdered no of course no one wants to
see that and I speaking to my and it's
awful what he's had to enure his office
essentially being attacked and set on
fire the threats he's received and now
actually Houses of Parliament have put
in place over the years more things to
protect MPS Security in their offices at
their homes and it's something that's
constantly being reviewed but I think as
well as looking at that which you're
right of course we should do which are
the practical things we've also got to
look at the ideology that is driving
that kind of behavior and that's making
sure that we tackle it at its route
right we can't have is that kind of
extremist ideology festering in
communities on our streets that leads
people to behave in that particular way
and I think that's equally important do
you think the idea of each of them
having a security guard is a good idea
no well generally these are better
answers that well questions that are
better put to the police and our
security services I mean look there
there may well be an argument for that
seems to me they're very vulnerable in
their constituency offices every MP and
and more protection has been put in
place at most MP's constituency office
officers where they have access to
systems syst to assume you're looking at
this I in general as I was actually I
talking to Mike and talking to others we
always want to make sure that MPS are
safe and as you said it's incredibly sad
what we've seen But as well as the
Practical security of MPS which is
Paramount it's the culture that leads to
that type of extremist behavior that
doesn't just impact MPS it impacts other
people as well and we've got to be
equally tough on calling out that kind
of behavior as well do you get told
about threats to you
uh I mean yes is it unnerving yeah I
mean look I'm very fortunate in the
sense I have an incredible team of
people who you know job it is to to keep
me safe and it comes with the territory
um I people remember you know you know
people came and protested at my house
which was obviously slightly unset
actually I think that happened literally
while yeah I was uh on my way to over to
the states with you on the plane that
was happening and that that is unnerving
because you know when your home is in Ed
in that way it feel you feel very
vulnerable but it's just about me it
actually goes to a broader thing I want
my two girls to be able to grow up in a
society that's safe which is why you
know I'm quite focused on putting more
police officers on the street crucially
giving them the tough Powers they need
to say confiscate knives off people um
which is really important make sure we
have things like CCTV and Street
lighting so you know girls like mine
when they grow up and women can feel
safe when they walk home at night like
that's the type again that's the type of
society that I want type of country that
we should people feel concerned when
they see these Pro Palestinian marches
many of whom are Marching completely
peacefully and for all the right reasons
uh and should be respected but there are
plenty of people brazenly flouting the
laws supporting Hamas chanting Jihad
chanting from The River To The Sea and I
think people feel that more should be
done to stop that that that if if more
is not done then it it fuels that kind
of extremism and emboldens it yeah which
is completely wrong and some of the
scenes that we've seen are unacceptable
I mean the rise of anti-Semitism in
particular over the last few months is
appalling I mean in our country in this
age Jewish people feel genuinely I mean
my my friends your friends was when
their kids are not wearing their school
uniform right when they're hiding their
star of Davids I mean this is what do
you feel yeah I feel shocked to my core
that in our country in this age that has
happened happened that people feel they
have to hide their identity it's
obviously appalling so what are we doing
well we're giving more funding to the
organization that protects Jewish places
of faith for example and others and
we're talking to the police about
whether extra powers are needed to
properly police these protests so that
is a conversation where I've been very
clear if we think that there are new
powers that they need in order to
effectively deal with some of the things
that we're all seeing then we are very
open to doing that and legislating and
bringing forward quite tough things um
but right now if there is someone that's
breaking the law I've been very clear
with all the police those people should
face the full force of the LA the law
there should be absolutely you know no
tolerance for this and when people are
doing things that we can all see with
our own eyes or people sharing videos
the police should be going after those
people and getting them locked up I
interviewed an NHS doctor of more than
20 years wahed Shader who also had a
name Abdul wahed he was the leader of
the islamist group hisb Tera Britain uh
and he'd been a NHS doctor the entire
time that he was also running this group
you've just as a government prescribed
them as a terror group
he is still registered with the General
Medical Council I mean what should
happen so I think my understanding is
actually that the NHS are looking into
all this suspended yeah so I think
they're looking into that and obviously
professional bodies independent from the
government we've been very clear about
hisb but terer they should be a
prescribed terrorist organization we're
bringing forward the legislation to do
that and again you know question for K
starma he Once Upon a Time represented
his but terer actually he he supported
them in resisting prescription ion
elsewhere and it's like that's who he
was on the side of we're busy trying to
ban these people and he was busy trying
to you think he's a terrorist
sympathizer well the facts speak for
themselves right like he there he was he
was their lawyer when they were trying
to resist this we've just prescribed
them because we think that's what they
are and I just speak again these things
speak to people's values right as a
general principle you shouldn't be able
to continue as an NHS doctor if you are
leading this group in this country yeah
well from this moment on remember these
things are forward looking but it's has
clearly questions to answer which the
NHS are rightly looking at because he
came on my show and he was so Brazen I
mean really Brazen it celebrated October
the 7th he felt it was resistance forget
punch in the face forget without it's
not obviously right for me to comment on
individual people but we just be clear
forget about working in a particular
place it is illegal for a prescri for a
prescribed terrorist organization for
someone to be glorifying that
organization and what they do is already
illegal under our law and that's same in
these protests when you see people
glorifying what Hamas have done that is
against the law I felt like I know you
did that October the 7th was one of the
most horrendous Terror attacks of modern
times and that Israel not only has a
duty to defend itself but as a moral
compulsion to protect his people right I
think we would feel the same way here
the big question is whether what they've
been doing since is proportionate in
your estimation is it proportionate
given the massive civilian death toll
and in particular
the number of children and women being
killed yeah so actually where where you
first started is a place that I start
you know imagine if that had happened
here over a thousand people women
children
slaughtered raped all of this absolutely
appalling Act of terrorism and I think
Israel as any country would has not just
the right but the duty to defend itself
and its people and make sure that that
doesn't ever happen again and that means
going after Hamas and I think as I said
it's not just a right I think that's a
duty that anyone would expect of their
own government if something like that
happened to them but it is also
incumbent on Israel to take every care
to avoid harming civilians and I've made
that point repeatedly to prime minister
Netanyahu and you know I'm concerned
about the loss of civilian life in Gaza
too many civilians have lost their lives
and there are people who are in
Desperate Straits from a humanitarian
perspective which is why we ' been
trying very hard to get more Aid into
Gaza again I've kept pushing the prime
minister to open up more Aid routes the
UK's doing CE fine now we've been very
clear that we think there should be an
immediate pause to get hostages out
because remember Hamas still are holding
many hostages I think there should be an
immediate pause to get hostages out to
get more Aid in and build the conditions
for a sustainable ceasefire but for it
to be sustainable and truly sustainable
you know we have to address the
situation of Hamas we can't have a
terrorist organization still in in
charge we can't have them able to fire
Rockets into Israel so as part of a
sustainable ceasefire those things need
to be addressed but look in the
immediacy do I want a pause to get
hostages out and Aid in yes we do and
that's what we've been calling for Ian
10,000 children in Gaza have been killed
19,000 more have been orphaned 65% or so
of Gaza has been flattened I mean is
what is going on is
devastating have you considered I mean
you in a moral quand as I've been about
the scale of this response and where
that limit should be before countries
like ours say enough whilst I support
and we support Israel's right to defend
itself and remove the threat that Hamas
poses to its people because we have to
start there in all cases imagine if that
had happened in our country what people
would rightly expect of the government
they have to do that in a way that
avoids best as possible harming
civilians and too many have lost their
lives think and not enough Aid is
getting in is it helpful that prime
minister nety continues in his job it's
NE look it's never appropriate for for
me to comment on other countries
domestic politics right but what we will
do continually is call on Israel to
allow more Aid into Gaza to help all the
people as you said children who are not
getting the medicine the food that they
need and we're playing a leading role in
that people should be proud we've triple
the amount of Aid into the region
recently when I spoke to prime minister
Netanyahu I said why can't we open up
another Aid Route so we're not rying on
going Egypt does he want to hear anyone
who doesn't just go along with what he
wants to do yeah I mean he seems very
blinkered in what he's now doing
actually we've managed over time to
increase the number of trucks which are
going into Gaza still not enough but
compared to where we were at the
beginning we have persuaded him to open
up the crossing to get hundreds of
trucks in but we need hundreds more so
that there is progress that has been
made but it's nowhere near enough and I
will keep pushing so that we can get the
support that we need to people in Gaza
and at the same time work as you were
talking about work for that sustainable
ceasefire your foreign secretary Lord
Cameron uh has signaled what appears to
be quite a shift in UK policy this week
when he said that the political
perspective of a credible route to a
Palestinian State a new future must be
given to Palestinians it needs to be
irreversible it's not entirely in our
gift but Britain and our partners can
help by confirming our commitment to a
sovereign viable Palestinian State and
our vision for
composition and crucially must State our
clear intention to Grant a recognition
including at the United Nations that
does seem to be a move in our policy as
a country no it's look our position is
the same and we David was saying like we
are committed to a two-state solution
right we absolutely are committed that's
been the long-standing position of the
UK government and actually what's
happened over the last few months has
reminded us that we need to redouble our
efforts to bring that about working with
all our partners in the region I went
very soon after the attacks to meet with
everyone in the region to talk about
this and we're playing a role I met with
a president of the Palestinian Authority
specifically to talk about about this
but we have to think about that in the
context of what's going on right now and
that's why the immediate Primacy is to
get Aid in get hostages out build the
conditions for a sustainable would you
countenance if you were prime minister
actually saying that we now consider
there's a Palestinian State before a
conclusion to a peace and that's where I
think that there has been that's the way
people have perceived his comments to be
Tak and that's not the the government's
long-standing position has been that we
will recognize a Palestinian State at
the time that it's most conducive to the
peace process so only once the process
is finished yeah I think it's hard you
would preempt it's hard to the
conclusion of that but it's a it's it's
a difference yeah and I think it's been
over I said I think it's been over
interpreted like what we are absolutely
committed to as a two-state solution the
recognition of pal
should come at a point where that is
most conducive to the overall process
but at the moment you're not looking to
preempt anything no at the moment what
we're looking to do is build the
conditions to get hostages out Aid in a
sustainable ceasefire that looks forward
to the future that the foreign secretary
talked about where Israelis and
Palestinians can live side by side both
with dignity with peace with security
and opportunity when you look at the
resolution of the troubles in Northern
Ireland and it's very encouraging that
we're looking to see the power sharing
executive is now going to be back up and
running and congratulations on that it's
a significant achievement but do you see
parallels between Northern Ireland and
Israel Palestine for many decades it
looked like there could be no resolution
in Northern irand and then there was do
you think we can achieve the same Middle
East I I'm I'm obviously newer to this
but Northern Ireland is closer to home
and important to me is the UK prime
minister and I am pleased that we have
been able to resolve the situation in
Northern Ireland because fundamentally
there's millions of people who have been
without a government for too long there
is now the very real Prospect of the
executive being back up and running in
Northern Ireland people having the
devolved government that they deserve
and need to address all the things that
are going on and that is really positive
and and I've learned through that
process more about the necessity of
sitting down and talking to people
working through problems it shows that
when we can take on big problems
we can fix them and that's my take away
from the experience in Northern Ireland
and actually I'm confident that that can
be done elsewhere as
well we're here thanks for joining us
you're with talk TV on TV on radio
online and on your smart
speaking criminals to using XL Bully
dogs as weapons to threaten others no
matter how well trained most dog owners
will tell you a dog can turn you know
what I love about t today we do do it
all sunak sella
scon a woman can become a man and a man
can become a woman and if you think that
you're certifiably
insane slick Wishy seemed intelligent
forensic even a bit of a Statesman the
type of man you trust to look after your
house while you went on
holiday this concept that actually kids
wouldn't carry knives if they could go
and play Tiddly Winks at the you know
the corner of the street or whatever I
think it's a
nonsense happy
we slick it and timorous Beast panics
in K starm accused the government of
failing a generation after a record
number of young people were killed last
year using a knife or sharp object we
need to make sure that when we say we're
going to ban them we actually do ban
them there are so many politicians now
who just said my dad was a
boss you're David Cameron no he
wasn't was like brought to you by
sadique Khan the mayor of London very
rarely meet anybody that says you know
the thing about London is it's got a
great mayor sadique Khan brilliant
guy in the cities there are areas where
there are no vegetables it's
particularly difficult for those people
to do what Mark is saying if he comes up
with this argument again I'll sit on
him stop creating all of these funny
little factions with their funny little
names the new conservatives the ERG the
common sense research group the red wool
red prouser popcor I mean popcorn what
what is that if you're talking about
multiculturalism it's workingclass white
boys who get put in the Army the poorest
people in society are the ones who are
going to be put on the front line
something is going horribly wrong we can
do a lot better Donald Trump didn't just
win he obliterated this is a guy facing
nearly a 100 criminal charges and yet
all that's done is actually Mak him more
popular Trump is canny enough to know
that all publicity is good publicity I
don't want a president who's been
impeached if he's able to bamboozle you
that's the way it goes did my 6 months I
came back nobody would touch me I put my
head down and persisted and carried on
when I say I am God I'm not joking did
you feel Elvis was controlling I've been
answering your question you answer mine
it's actually not my job to answer your
questions I've asked you two questions
should a mass stay in power and are they
a teror group you're refusing to answer
either of them that is very telling talk
TV is the only place where you get the
truth you've done a book on poetry
poetry and music for the many I love
poetry we can agree on
that this is talk
[Music]
TV you've been very strong in supporting
Ukraine which I've been pleased to see I
think it's the right thing for our
country to be doing do you fear that the
support In America which is going to be
critical may be drifting the wrong way
so when I was in the states last year I
spent a lot of time on the hill talking
to people from both parties in Congress
and I I didn't detect that I think there
is actually broad bipartisan support in
the US for more support to Ukraine I
think what people unsurprisingly want to
see given that the US is by far and away
the single biggest provider of that
support is they want to see other allies
stepping up now if I was a US taxpayer
if I was a US politician I'd probably
say the same thing Hang on we're going
to do this what about everyone else and
that's why it was important to me that
the UK demonstrated leadership I was the
first foreign leader there this year it
was my first visit we were the first
people to announce significant support
for this year first country to sign a
multi ukra is great but that that will
help actually make the argument in
America that they can count on us as an
ally so they're not shouldering the
entire burden themselves if Russia was
to turn its turrets in our direction is
this country
prepared properly to defend itself yes
and one of my first job is to keep
everybody safe and unfortunately you
know the world is becoming less safe and
we can see that obviously with the
situation in Russia and Ukraine but most
recently we've been seeing it in the Red
Sea where for the first time in decades
people are trying to fire missiles at
one of our Royal Navy vessels they're
disrupting shipping uh and that is
actually we can't pretend these things
don't affect us cuz every ship that has
to get re-rooted ultimately adds more
cost to the things that people are
buying every day and we've all just
lived through the impact of that because
of our energy bills so I actually oddly
by coincidence was in Ukraine at the
same time as that we were participating
with the US on self-defense strikes
against the hooti group and that kind of
demonstrates the world we're living in
but that's why we've increased our
investment in defense spending um and
it's something that I spend more many in
the armed forces and I've got my brother
was is a retired army colonel my sister
married a guy's now retired was an army
colonel a lot of concern about the the
actual numbers we have in our armed
forces are you concerned we don't have
enough so my job is to put the right
investment in which we've done I did
that first of all as Chancellor where we
put the largest increase of funding into
the mod since the end of the Cold War
and we've committed to maintain that and
increasing it over over time but in
general do I think we are well protected
Ed well invested yes we are the second
biggest defense spender in NATO we have
mess to to Putin I mean as you can see
from what we've done in Ukraine like we
will stand up for the things that we
believe in we won't let aggression go
unchecked and unpunished and actually
what he can see is that we have come
together with our allies he that we are
not divided what he has served to do is
unite everybody increase the amount that
we're all spending in defense got new
members of NATO so actually
strategically this has already been a
failure for him uh because he has not
achieved any of those objectives and
we're in a much stronger position now to
resist further aggression from him and
others around the world that would seek
to do likewise let's turn to the pledges
that was the
warmup you made five pledges in your
January 2023 speech you said these are
the people's priorities they are your
government's priorities we will either
have achieved them or not no trick no
ambiguity rather delivering for you or
we're not we will rebuild trust in
politics through action or not at all so
I ask you to judge us on the effort we
put in and the results we achieve I will
only promise what I can deliver and I
will deliver what I promise that's a big
statement you know I thought it was
ballsy if I'm honest with you for a
politician who's just become Prime
Minister to say that and then to specify
five
criteria how many of the five do you
think you've met well I think we've made
good progress on all of them and we
should go through how many of you met as
we see well we should go through because
we're going to I just wonder in totality
out of the five I think we've made when
you're score scoreboarding yourself what
do you think I think we've made good
progress on the economic ones which are
the first three to Har inflation grow
the economy and reduce debt we have not
made progress on cutting waiting lists
which we'll get into and we have made
progress on stopping the boats but there
is more to do and we'll get on to that
as well U but I should take a step back
before we get into it you said it was
ballsy and surprising but that was what
I wanted to do I wanted to do something
different in the sense that I wanted to
be a different type of politician and I
wanted to say look you can hold me
accountable for things I'm not going to
obfuscate none of this was easy and I
wanted to be held accountable for them
as I said you come back in a year here
we are well the reason I thought it was
ballsy was I knew that you would be
judged now as you're in an election year
and if you didn't deliver on those five
pledges then the the the electorate
might take a rather dim view of it given
the pronouncement you made back in
January 23 and I think I think actually
as we were talking right at the
beginning I think people are completely
fair-minded they will judge us on the
effort we're putting in the results
we're achieving and they'll make their
determination about the future actually
about who's going to keep delivering
change that they want to see I think
well let me put my teacher hat on yeah
let's go through let's go through the
report yeah uh Mr sunak um well the
first one was to have inflation by the
end of 2023 you did it now most people
thought you probably would and who
here's my question for you do you want
to actually take credit for harving
inflation because I don't remember you
taking any blame on the way up as it
soar to 11% is it really not the case
that it's mostly out of your control
inflation so yes it's great that you've
met your pledge but how much of that is
down to you look well all of these
things is's always a mix of factors but
that was the most important thing for me
to focus on when I got this job the cost
of living dominated everything it's the
biggest impact on families up and down
the country and I said we needed to half
inflation because that's best thing we
could do to help everyone and I'm
pleased that we've more than delivered
it as you said from 11% down to down to
and all I'd say is there was a big
period in the Middle where it wasn't
obvious that we were going to hit it and
I could find lots of you know
journalists commentating and saying that
that's not going to happen so I don't
but how much do you think was down to
you I do cuz I don't think these things
happen by accident I don't think these
things happen by accident it was not a
foregone conclusion it requires
governments to take difficult decisions
and there'll be other things that people
have wanted me to do spend money on this
borrow that where I've said no that's
not the right thing to do because we've
got to get want the credit for getting
it down to 4% should I be blaming you
for it getting up to 11 to start with
you people no doubt were Sor yeah but
would it'd be right to I mean there will
be a mix of factors in all the it's not
that simple when you're talking about
the economy there's obviously a mix of
factors but all I can do is control the
things that I'm responsible for and
principally for a government when it
comes to inflation that's about how much
are we borrowing and spending and if you
borrow too much as a government that
adds to inflation that's relatively
straightforward and unfortunately right
it's easy for governments to do
borrowing because that's taking the easy
way out then they don't have to say no
to anybody so I had to spend a lot of
last year making some difficult
decisions that that weren't easy but
that's what I want to deliver for the
country is what's long term and first
pledge tick right you're one for one
it's a good start second one grow the
economy I would categorize you as being
right on the wire on this uh pending the
news you're going to get in two weeks
which will establish whether the fourth
quarter was positive or negative and if
it was negative that would be two
successive quarters in negative we would
officially be in recession that's going
to be a big figure for you 15th of
February isn't it yes than and all the
indications are all the indications are
it may not be good news so if it's not
good news and we do actually are
officially tipping into recession would
you accept that that has failed so again
you when I got the job what were people
predicting they were predicting almost a
yearlong recession where the economy
would shrink by 1 and a half% that was
what was forecast when I got this job by
the independent
forecasters that clearly has a happened
now you're right we're on the wire of
has it grown a little bit has it broadly
stayed flat but fundamentally what was
predicted was a year-long recession
where the economy shrank by quite a lot
that has not happened and we've
outperformed countries and we've
outperformed European countries like
Germany and others can you say as we sit
here you have grown the economy yeah I'm
I'm confident since we last say it yeah
I confident that we will be able to keep
growing the economy will I mean have you
actually grown it you think I think
relative to what was predicted we
definitely grown it you're being a
politician now no but that cont you want
to be a straight talker a politician
would say well you know compared to what
could have happened but actually I think
it's both I think they're both if you
want to be judged specifically on the
pledge would it not be honest to say
well we haven't grown the economy but
we're hoping to we don't know is the
answer because as you said we'll find
out in a couple of weeks uh but I said
and as I said we'll see what it is right
but fundamentally also worth bearing in
mind the context and that's why people
make their own judgment right we were
forecast to have a really bad time and a
big long recession and we're now talking
about we've certainly avoided that and
then how much has it grown or has it
stayed I'm not going to give you a yes
yeah I'm not going to give you a no yet
because it might surprise us in two
weeks but it's a big moment for you in
two weeks yes but again you don't want
to be the Prime Minister after saying in
to grow the economy to wake up and
discover that technically we went into
recession but again it doesn't stop
there does it no no it's about what else
is happening and if you think about you
rather avoid that of course you'd always
rather avoid it but it's important to
look at other things as well real wages
are growing so people's wages are
growing faster than prices for 6 months
in a row our manufacturing sector last
year overtook France's in the size of
how big it is we have more big
technology companies grown in the UK
than France Germany and Sweden combined
and we're getting new investment in from
people like Nissan into Sunderland oread
of building an offshore Wind Farm off
the east coast Microsoft are doubling
their footprint in the UK so actually I
think the momentum on the economy is
very positive to be fair though I can't
give you a yes yet well that I think
actually well we'll see where we get
there in a couple of weeks but remember
it doesn't just stop there we can't just
give up there we I'm going to leave it
as a possibly as a possibly we're the
bias to the positive compared to where
we were uh number three reducing the
national debt I think we have to agree
that that has not happened yeah but we
were always clear about you agree that
no no no no no no no no I was very clear
when I did that press conference we
always measure these things according to
these independently measured fiscal
rules right we have rules that we set
out for what's happening the public
sector net debt was
97.7% of GDP in December 20123 it was
94.8% in January 2023 that is not going
down that's going up it is absolutely
according to the rules that are
independently checked by the office for
Budget responsibility forecast to
decline within our rules I know but you
okay but you're talking about going
forward but that is how we measure debt
and I was very transparent about that at
the time your actual pledge say we will
make sure national debt is falling so we
can secure the future of Public Services
now are you saying you didn't mean in
the next year we were crystal clear at
the time I was clear no no no because
this is not me marking my own homework
we have an independent body that marks
our homework you did jump ahead of
yourself and said in November you
publicly said it was falling and you had
to be corrected and you were warned be
careful about statistics if you're prime
minister but on this I'm very confident
you were wrong to do that no because
what I'm referring to very clearly is
the rules that we have set out that it
independently checked someone else marks
our homework the office of budget
responsibility and they have if I'm I'm
marking your homework but they've been
very clear that we're meeting I'm your
homework and right now I can't give you
a success no you can not for this year
not since I last saw you yeah you can
you could say looking ahead yeah but
that but that's always how we measure
debt that it's on a downward trajectory
that's how you build certainty and
security for public finances that's the
fiscal rules that the chancellor set out
before I even gave that speech we'd set
out the fiscal rul about this but no no
you have to that well I don't accept you
you you certainly haven't cut it in the
first year no but it's the the rules
that we set out the rules that we set
out have been completely and utterly met
okay every time the chancer has stood up
the independent body has said yes meting
a ruls it's it's massively on track to
happen Okay NHS and it's got even
better we're here thanks for joining us
you're with talk TV on TV on radio
online and on your smart
speaking criminals to using XL Bully
dogs as weapons to threaten others no
matter how well trained most dog owners
will tell you a dog can turn you know
what I love about to today we do it all
sunak sella
scon woman can become a man and a man
can become a woman and if you think that
you're certifiably
insane slick Wishy seemed intelligent
forensic even a bit of a Statesman the
type of man you trust to look after your
house while you went on
holiday this concept that actually kids
wouldn't carry knives if they could go
and play Tiddly Winks at the you know
the corner of a street or whatever I
think it's a
nonsense happy THS night we slick it C
and timorous beasty open up panics in
nist K stas accused the government of
failing a generation after record number
of young people were killed last year
using a knife or sharp object we need to
make sure that when we say we're going
to ban them we actually do ban them
there are so many politicians now who
just said my dad was a
boss you're David Cameron no he
wasn't was like brought to you by St KH
the mayor of London very rarely meet
anybody that says you know the thing
about London it's got a great mayor
sadique Khan brilliant
guy in the cities there are areas where
there are no vegetables it's
particularly difficult for those people
to do what Mark is saying if he comes up
with this argument against again I'll
on
her stop creating all of these funny
little factions with their funny little
names the new conservatives the ERG the
common sense research group the red wool
red trouser popcorn I mean popcorn what
what is that if you're talking about
multiculturalism it's workingclass white
boys who get put in the Army the poorest
people in society are the ones who are
going to be put on the front line
something is going horribly wrong we
could do a lot better Donald Trump
didn't just win he obliterated this is a
guy facing nearly a 100 criminal charges
and yet all that's done is actually make
him more popular Trump is canny enough
to know that all publicity is good
publicity I don't want a president who's
been impeached if he's able to bamboozle
you or that's the wake it up I did my 6
months I came back nobody would touch me
I put my head down and persisted and
carried on when I say I am God I'm not
joking did you feel Elvis was
controlling I've been answering your
question you answer it's actually not my
job to answer your questions I've asked
you two questions should a mass stay in
power and are they a terror group you're
refusing to answer either of them that
is very telling talk TV is the only
place where you get the truth you've
done a book on poetry poetry and music
for the many I love poetry we can agree
on
that
NHS waiting this we have not made enough
progress you failed on that pledge
because you said any sh waiting will
fall uh in fact they are slightly coming
down now but the waiting is still nearly
half a million more than it was at the
start of last year you accept that that
yes and we all know the reasons for that
and what I would say to people is look
we've invested record amounts in the NHS
more doctors more nurses more scanners
all these things mean that the NHS is
doing more today than it ever has been
but industrial action has had an impact
and in November you talked about this in
November we had a month where there was
no strikes for the first time and do you
know what happened to the waiting list
they fell by almost 100,000 me impartial
observers have calculated probably half
of that waiting list can be ascribed to
the
strikes I but you had one month where we
had words they were still have gone up
but they wouldn't have gone up as fast
yeah it just we had a month in November
no strikes what happened waiting list
fell by 100,000 you said you said in
your January 2023 speech I know there
are challenges in A&E people understand
to be anxious when they see ambulances
queuing outside hospitals you should
know we're taking urgent action and
going back to your foreign secretary
when he was Prim in 2011 I refuse to go
back to the days when people have to
wait for hours and then to be seen an
A&E and so we will ensure we get control
back at waiting times and yet a new
statistic that came out yesterday says
nearly 35,000 patients a month waiting
for 12 hours or more for a hospital bed
in 2023 that's a fact check analysis of
NHS England data it's 3,000 times higher
than in 2011 after 14 years of Tory rule
that's not a good thing no that's not
good enough and that's why we've been
working very hard to bring down the
people waiting for A&E treatment can can
I tell you a personal story at this
stage because I found it quite shocking
so my mother is 79 and she had a heart
attack 3 month months ago and she was
taken to a local hospital they said
you've had a heart attack we got to get
you to a cardiac unit down in Brighton
on suex coast and they blew her in an
ambulance at midnight fortunately my
sister was able to go with them and she
was seen when she got there and then she
was put on a trolley in A&E in a
corridor for nearly seven
hours the heart monitor battery ran out
nobody fixed it at one stage no nurse
came for three or 4 hours there were
between she reckons 35 and 40 other
people on trolleys in the corridors of
this A&E most of them elderly without
people she said old men were begging for
bottles to urinate into others were
crying in pain or discomfort she said it
was a scene out of a war zone and she
couldn't believe what she was seeing and
she was also terrified of course having
been told you've had a heart attack that
no one was putting her into the unit and
actually trying to fix her now once she
got up there the treatment she got was
world class she was fixed within 36
hours but I you know I brought this one
picture to show you that's you that's my
mom who's worked all her life right paid
her taxes all her life and when she
really needed the NHS yeah eventually
then HS came through but she could have
died on that trolley and I think that's
shocking yeah that is a shocking story
and I'm really glad that she's feeling
better now and send her my best and I'm
glad she got the treatment that she
needed this was a Monday night prime
minister this wasn't even the weekend
yeah it's not even a major city this is
Brighton and there were 40 yard people
on trolleys in a corridor I mean I found
that just how can this be happening yeah
it's it's not good enough the
performance in a and ambulance waiting
time has has has the Tory government
since 2010 has it failed on NHS do you
accept that no I don't because I think
we also are dealing with the backlog on
the legacy of covid which has just had
an impact and we can't escape that right
when you shut down the country and the
NHS for the best part of two years that
has had an impact on everything since
then and we just have to recognize that
reality and what we can do is put more
money in which we are hire more people
which we are put more diagnostic
treatment in to get people the the tests
and the checks and the scans they need
quicker and ultimately the NHS is doing
more today than it's ever done in the
past and as we saw in November it made a
difference on the waiting list ambulance
times this winter A&E times this winter
are better than they were when I first
got this job so that shows that we're
making progress but fundamentally is it
good enough no um but we are making a
difference to people just this week for
example in a different way we've made it
easier for people to get medicines that
they need for things like sore throats
ear infections where now they can go and
see their pharmacist I think that's a
very good initiative but I do think
you've got to to as a government sort
this problem out of a& the number of
horror stories I heard once we started
telling people about what happened to my
mother was really shocking almost
everyone that had to go into an A&E had
a similar Horror Story and I don't blame
the staff they completely rushed off
their feet and as I say once you get up
into the place you're supposed to be the
the treatment's amazing we have an
amazing Health Service it's just getting
up there is hell yeah and we don't have
enough doctors or nurses that we train
here at home so one of the other things
I decided to do as Prime Minister was
for the first time in the NHS the 75
years actually have a long-term
Workforce plan so now we've just started
training more doctors more nurses more
dentists more of everything so that over
time we will be less reliant on people
needing to come here from abroad and
we'll have more doctors and nurses in
all our Hospitals now that will
obviously take time to make an impact
but it's an example of me doing what I
think is right in the long term no one's
ever done that before because generally
they don't think they'll be around to
see the benefits of it right I think be
part of the yeah but I've made the
decision to do it one thing you said to
me last time we spoke was you were going
to sort or look at you said the car
parking for NH staff issue it's now
completely out of control it's risen by
50% in a year the price of parking a car
at hospitals in England nearly 50
million pounds is paid by NHS staff to
have the privilege to park in hospitals
where they're saving lies I think this
it's unconscionable so after we spoke
last time I went back and looked at into
it and I'm actually able to report that
we have now rolled out across all NHS
trusts the free parking policy which is
focus on those who need it the most so
people for example blue badge holders
are those with disabilities uh people
who have multiple outpatient
appointments because of their condition
parents who have got sick children who
need to stay overnight and all NHS staff
who are working night sh why should any
member of pay well all of the people
that why should mentioned why should any
of them pay why should any of them pay
why should any NHS staff pay for the
privilege lots of people get lots of
people get to work in different ways
right so those are all the people that
we have targeted free parking on I think
most people would agree those are the
most at need groups and when it comes to
nurses as you mentioned actually what we
arranged this year is for nurses to have
a very good pay rise so some a nurse
that was so they could spend it on
parking well I just making sure but
remember everyone comes every I think
there a no brainer if you want to be
popular with the Health Service prime
minister don't make them pay for the
privilege of parking in well what they
wanted when they spoke to us making sure
that their staff are paid well and and
actually look you know a typical nurse
with five years experience they got pay
rise of around ,700 they got an extra
bonus of around £2,000 and just this
year they're receiving a tax car around
450 you take another look at it I I will
always look to see how we can support
our staff because I agree with you they
do an incredible job and we're very
lucky to have them so fail on NHS
waiting list fifth stop the boats uh you
said we will pass new laws to stop small
boats making sure if you come to this
country illegally you are detained and
swiftly removed now on the plus side
you've reduced the number of people last
year who came over on the boats from
45,000 down to 29,000 many due to the
deal with Albania big tick I mean that's
a big drop congratulations here's the
bit I don't get I've never understood
this Rwanda thing from the start of it
during it and where we are now it seems
to me a completely cand in policy but
honest I've made no bones about this
I've been saying it the whole time where
even if it succeeds even if miraculously
you get it through Parliament you end up
just with maybe 200 people at vast
expense being sent to Rwanda and if they
have a legitimate Asylum case we leave
them there none of this makes any sense
to me and I'm curious I mean Philip
Johnson in the telegraph so why Mr sunac
decided to pin his entire premise ship
to the removal of a few hundred at most
migrants Rwanda will have historians
scratching their heads in perplexity and
I agree with it why is this the hill you
want to die on why is there not a better
way to do this okay there lots of there
well one is we've been through lots of
other things as well it's not the only
thing I'm I'm working on but it's a
really important one because it's a
matter of fairness first and foremost
because I think actually people coming
here illegally undermine the sense of
fairness on which our we can all agree
on that right so then you say what do we
do about it well Rwanda is one part of a
plan as you said we've already got the
numbers down by a third which has never
happened before right so that is
progress we you would have been sitting
here and saying to me look at that and I
would have gone well done yeah so on
Rwanda why do you need it because you
need a deterrent because simply if
someone comes here illegally they
shouldn't be allowed to stay we must be
able to remove them and they can't all
go back to the country they came from
because it's very clearly not safe or a
war zone but you need to have a safe
alternative to send them and that's why
you need a policy like Rwanda and I
believe that when we get up and running
when we get flights going off and it's
uncapped so we can send lots of people
there then people will stop coming and
you know why I know that that's going to
work is because as you acknowledged it's
worked with Albania if I said to you
I'll bet you ,000 to a refugee charity
you don't get anybody on those planes
before the election will you take that
back well I well I want to get the
people on the planes right of course I
want to get the people on the planes
right I want to get the people on the
planes I'm working incredibly hard to
get the people do you think that should
be the priority when at the same time
time the on just predicted we could hit
73 million people who in this country
like coming in not on boats but coming
in the normal immigration system by
2036 most people go well that seems
massively more I people talk to me a lot
about illegal migration as I'm sure they
talk to about you it's important that we
grip it and Rwanda is one part of an
overall plan that is working and and you
say you scratching your head Albania is
an example of why it's working
we created a new returns agreement with
Albania it meant that if people came
here illegally we could send them back
and you know what they stopped coming
Rwanda will do the same thing for us I
do not think it's going to work for you
okay well we'll have to agree to
disagree that's my Grim prediction but
you don't have an alternative way to
solve that problem then uh no I'm not
prime minister right so and nor of the
labor party by the way nobody does right
and and if you don't believe in solving
the problem that's one thing I do I
think the British people do if you do
you need pledge I'm going to give you
I'm going to give you a half pass okay
and on legal migration we've taken
action we're going to cut the numbers by
about 300,000 more than anyone's ever
done before that kicked in at the
beginning of this year and it will start
making a difference final
question you've lasted longer than Alis
congratulations labor are 20 points
ahead when he going to call the election
when he going to go to the people and
test their confidence in you look I
spoke about that at the beginning of
this year so I haven't got more to add
on it but the choice at that election is
what matters Ms and the choice I think
is becoming increasingly clear because
if you stick with the plan that is
working of course as we've been through
we have to make more progress but the
plan is working we are making progress
the alternative is Labour party and K
stara who would just take us back to
square one because as you know he's had
four years he can't tell you what he
would do differently because he doesn't
have a plan promise here's what I say at
the end is that uh K stama has
resolutely not delivered on his pledges
to do interview with me for be Morgan
uncensored you've now done two in the
space of the last year I appreciate that
I think you do put yourself up to be
held to account more than he does if
he's watching this sakir you know where
to find me but I do you said you would
get me back a year later you have done I
appreciate your time and I wish you uh
well I wish you whatever success you
deserve this year prime minister well I
appreciate that and it's good to and
that to be seen doesn't it well I
actually as I said I think we are
pointing in the right direction you
still going to be here in a year's time
I plan on being so you'll come back for
that third interview we'll do the
postelection interview back in this room
in a year all right done deal good to
see you you
[Music]
too we're here thanks for joining us
you're with talk TV on TV on radio
online and on your smart
speaking criminals to using XL Bully
dogs as weapons to threaten others no
matter how well Tred most dog owners
will tell you a dog can turn do you know
what I love about talk today we do it
all sunak sella
scon a woman can become a man and a man
can become a woman and if you think that
you're certifiably in